The Joe Rogan experience.
What are these?
Is this Elon Musk space station on Mars neighborhood sucks.
That's like living in Barstow for the rest of your life.
What do you even see there?
Yeah.
If you get trapped in Barstow in a glass bubble,
like halfway to Vegas.
Hey,
remember the files fair?
Pauly shore.
Yeah.
No,
but that they did a real one.
Oh,
that's right.
We by
the actual bias.
Pauly shore and who else?
Uh,
Stephen Baldwin.
Yeah,
that's right.
The biosphere like that.
How'd that,
that didn't go so well.
No.
People went crazy.
They go crazy.
Why don't we do that again?
People go crazy,
man.
You don't want,
they don't want to be locked together with each other.
It's not normal for everybody.
We just stuck in some bubble with each other.
It's been 25 years since biosphere,
since eight scientists sealed themselves in the biosphere for two whole years.
What ended up happening to them?
I forget.
It probably went on fuck rampage took more than three months just to make pizza.
Wow.
What does that mean?
Did they bring a guy they probably to great ingredients from scratch or
something?
Oh No,
of course.
Oh yeah.
They had a live,
they had to be sustainable inside that little ecosystem where they allowed a
bang each other.
How could,
you forbid that how good your top people want to do in generic,
but it's work,
work,
environment,
harassment.
Yeah.
I guess you're right.
He up.
Who's HR?
Who's going to stop you?
That's right.
Who is HR?
So there's 25 people in their 25 scientists and that's the thing.
Do you think that if people,
if we didn't have laws,
you know,
lot of the society,
no police,
how will we just kill each other?
Yes.
[inaudible] it didn't happen.
They're like,
Ooh,
who was the law there and the bias?
No,
I think most of the time we don't even,
what does this say Jamie?
Nevertheless,
the team completed the mission emerging from the outside world after two years
of solitude.
Okay.
Um,
I think most of the time you don't need the law,
but is that because we know the law exists and people formulated society in the
sense that you could always count on the laws.
So that keeps people in check.
I don't know.
And it depends on where you live.
Like if you live in a poverty stricken crime ridden neighborhoods,
do you need the law of their more or do you need the law?
They're less like what?
What is,
what's is is maybe people being arrested a lot causing some of the problems that
you're seeing in that neighborhood.
And there's some of those arrests because of nonviolent drug offenses.
Like how much,
how much are you turning?
Cause there is a certain percentage of people that get turned into criminals
once they get introduced into the,
the judicial system as a nonviolent person.
That person who's just driving towards that,
you're stuck in a fucking,
uh,
full penitentiary with criminals.
Like real criminals,
like violent people.
And then you're just a guy who sells.
We'd be like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
Like fuck,
what am I doing here?
This is why,
this is why we need to analyze those,
uh,
isolated,
environments,
those isolated ecosystems with people that's never seen anyone from the outside
see how they handle shit,
kill each other and they kill people that don't pull their weight.
Should we give people kill the week?
No,
I don't think so.
There's,
there's a great book sapiens from uh,
Noah.
What is you've all Herati um,
it's a great book but it just outlines the history of the human race and these
various tribes that have dealt with like weird shit like that.
Like there's,
there's certain tribes that like when they see like old ladies that are moving
too slow or if a lot of these kids,
they just kill them ma'am.
Yeah.
And this one guy was talking about,
I think it was that book.
I'm pretty sure it was the,
that was sapiens.
I read a bunch of books or listened to,
I should say,
I don't want to lie and listen to him on tape.
A bunch of them back to back on runs.
Correct.
That we're dealing with this very same issue.
And,
um,
there was talking about this guy who was like call a few of his aunt's dam and
yeah.
And they were like,
all the old ladies are scared of him because he was the guy that they hired to
kill them when they weren't pulling their own weight.
And I'm like,
okay,
but maybe that,
is that a bad thing though?
Because if you're,
if you're part of it,
if you're that old lady,
if that's correct.
If you're part of an older tribe,
if you about our tribe,
right?
And you guys have to keep moving and keeping things going because you're going
to get killed by another tribe and then you have a weaker members of that tribe
that are holding the entire tribe back.
What do you do?
Your risky,
I mean to you,
that's the real question.
Would you,
would you,
would you know,
would you put a bullet in,
you know,
your friend's mom because she wasn't pulling her weight and because that,
that depends on the entire tribe itself.
She's stoned the whole tribe down.
See we,
that's the thing that you do when you don't have much.
Right.
When you have surplus like we have,
we,
we value,
our older people want to care for them.
Right.
Like,
and [inaudible] and stuff.
Yeah.
Like there's a,
there's a famous video of these two comedians.
You seen that video?
There's two comedians and find this lady who's trying to buy gas with like
pennies and shit and they give her money and she starts crying.
It's a tear.
Jerker it's a serious tear.
Jerker but what happens in the video?
They give her money.
They find some lady.
Yeah.
They just stay.
They just use two young guys get out and give this lady money and,
and she starts crying and yeah,
just like,
okay.
Gas was like five bucks a gallon.
I had close to probably pain with like pennies and shit.
She's just like,
she's,
yeah.
And so they give her some money and she's,
she's like weeping.
Yeah.
It's really,
she,
her husband died just a week ago.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's heavy to turn it off.
I'm gonna start crying.
Stop it.
I want to see you cry.
You don't know,
man.
Hey,
Joel was lost.
We cried,
uh,
not that long ago.
Really?
Yeah.
I cry for happy thing.
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
You don't cry for sad stuff?
Not as much,
man.
Yeah.
I'm all like,
if someone does something really amazing,
I'll start with,
yeah.
Really?
Yeah.
You saw my videos,
you like,
Oh God,
I've got to get him into this guy at the show.
Yeah.
When people do good things that cry.
I get,
I tear up for shit like that.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
Same here.
I'm not into dudes who cry about like stupid shit.
Yeah.
Like having too much money on food.
Oh God.
Shut up.
You got out,
man.
You know,
if he cry was it always moves?
Yeah.
No.
That's what happens when you drive and it says right.
Empty you dumb fucking idiot.
Jesus Christ.
Shabbat an eevee.